hello everyone this game comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber and I'm
sure you'll enjoy it as it's quite an
interesting game the game was played in
1980 it was played in SCARA Sweden and
it was the seventh European Championship
for men and in the official chess chess
games database the game is called the
incorrect opening why is it called
incorrect opening because we have world
champion Anatoly Karpov with the white
pieces he's playing against English
grandmaster anthony miles and anthony
miles was known for his unusual ideas in
the openings especially with the black
pieces and here he has an amazing
opportunity to prove his point that his
ideas aren't that bad because he has he
has the opportunity to use one of them
against Anatoly Karpov himself and by
doing that he will completely avoid any
opening theory that he knows Karpov is
far superior in now I believe this is
the second game I'm showing by Tony
miles and my channel the first one was
that game against Garry Kasparov as you
all know it was actually 20-miles who
played a training match with Garry
Kasparov six games in the end the match
ended with a five and a half to half in
Kasparov's favor and then after that
Tony miles said his famous sentence that
he thought he was playing against the
world champion but in the end he was
playing against a monster with 27 eyes
but in the end the legend of Kasparov
grew out of proportion and that sentence
got reduced to I thought I was playing
against a beast with a thousand eyes and
therefore Kasparov got his nickname a
beast with a thousand eyes so that's the
Tony miles I mentioned in my previous
video and it's quite a game so so let's
see it Karpov has the white pieces and
he opens with E for we have a six here
and this is something called the st.
George defense and Tony maws considered
it an improvement on b6 and you know
followed by Bishop to be seven because
here black immediately prepares b5 the
bishop will come to b7 and the ideas
will be similar but by playing b5 black
will already from the beginning be
controlling the c-4 square so we have b4
by Karpov
and b5 immediately Knight to f3 Bishop
to be seven and the Bishop to d3 now
defending the e4 pawn by Karpov Knight
to f6 Queen to e2 again defending d4
pawn and isse X now we had a four
immediately going for that pawn chain
Myles created on the Queen side we have
c5 and c5 does seem like very aggressive
it's only moved six and twenty miles
suggested that maybe even before is
playable but he decided to go for c5 we
have D captures on c5 Bishop captures on
c5 and here
Karpov goes for the very silent night to
d2 and twenty-mile says that Karpov
played that night the D to move
relatively fast and move worth
considering is definitely five after a
five a Knight to d5 now simply a key
actress on b5 a capture some b5 rook
captures Bishop captures and now Bishop
captures pawn on d5 so here white wins
upon black will be somewhat better in
development but I I don't see what what
problems Carver would have with this
position but as Karpov probably never
faced a six and the first move before he
didn't want to go into uncharted
territory here
so after Bishop captures and c5 Karpov
played Knight B to d2 and here before
immediately not allowing the following
variation I just showed he five by
Karpov now we have Knight to d5 and now
Knight to e4 attacking the bishop on c5
pressure back to e7 and now Karpov
castles we have Knight to c6 Bishop to
d2 and Queen to c7 attacking that epon
twice and here we have C for either
forcing black the capture on poisson and
c3 or to move the knight so miles
captures be captures and C 3 we have
knife characters now attacking the
knight on d5 Knight captures Bishop
captures and now the bishop on c3 is
protecting the e5 pawn all as well
Knight the b4 and here Karpov has to
make a very uncomfortable choice he has
the part part with
with a bishop he could play a move like
Bishop to be one but this will preserve
the bishop pair for some reason Karpov
decided not to go for this as black can
simply follow up with rook to c8 and
this night will be extremely stronger
than before at some point
Karpov will have to get rid of it by
giving up a one Bishop so after this
night to be four move Karpov played
Bishop capture some before Bishop
capture some before and now rook a to c1
attacking the Queen on c7 Queen to b6
and here we have Bishop to e4 here
Karpov wants the trade off
Tony's beautiful Bishop on b7 and here
after some consideration Miles played
castles and here we have a very exciting
position it's something you always want
to know you have a bishop eyeing the h7
point you have a knight ready to jump to
the g5 there is no Black Knight to be
able to help out with the defense and
there's Queen Annie - that is definitely
able to jump to h5 after this Knight
moves so all things considered Bishop
captures on h7 does seem like a
reasonable choice now this is a this is
a very nice position for you to analyze
yourself would you capture the bishop on
h7 and go for the attack Karpov actually
thought about this position for about
half an hour in their game and in the
end he decided to play Knight to g5 why
Karpov didn't go for Bishop captures on
h7 well because after Bishop captures
King characters and Knight to g5 check
of course you can't play King to g8
after Queen to h5 it's all over only way
to stop this black has to first give up
a piece by playing Bishop to g4 to
defend checkmate on h7 and after white
captures it you could play Bishop to e7
preventing the knife from jumping back
but then Roxy three rookies coming to h3
this is game over for black so after 90
g5 check
Tony would have to play King to g6 and
here it's the pretty standard setup
white would go Queen to g4 and here
black has to defend properly but as
Karpov thought about this for half an
hour he probably saw that after f5 and
Queen to g3
miles has this defensive resource of
Queen to d4 now this will meet the
discovered check by the knight with
Queen to g4
but even after Knight captures with
check and Queen to g4 defending Queen
captures pawn captures and now Knight
captures rook with check rook captures
let's say rook the c4 attacking the
bishop on d4 also the pawn on g4 a5
defending now rook captures and after
King to h7 now rook to c1 going for that
c7 square and after black block this
block this miles would have a bishop
prepare for a rook but carpel would have
three connected pawns three connected
extra pawns
so six points the three so it's hard to
say I mean the bishop pair is very
strong but three three extra pawns it's
it would be sort of an equal position
but Karpov obviously didn't like what he
saw but even even even considering a
position like this I don't know if Tony
miles will be able to beat this position
against Anatoly Karpov but you know that
that's one of the questions that will
never be answered
so after this castles Karpov didn't of
course go for Bishop captures on h7 if
for example Michael Tao wielded the
white pieces here I have no doubt we
would see a bishop characters on h7 move
but Carper went for Knight to g5 we had
h6 now and here
Bishop to h7 check mal says that he was
expecting Bishop captures and b7 simply
exchanging bishops and then Queen to e4
offering a trade of Queens but Karpov
actually goes for a for a pretty sneaky
idea
he plays Bishop to h7 check King to h8
and now Bishop back to be one with the
idea of course you can't capture the
night if you capture it and then comes
Queen to h5 this is checkmate
so after Bishop to b1 miles played
Bishop to e7 simply forcing that night
away from g5 carful played 90 to e4 and
here we have rook a to c8 and this is
another position where I mean it's a
perfectly
position both for black and white black
does have some advantage with the bishop
pair although he does have yet to
activate his bishop pair as at the
moment it's not as powerful as it could
be for example white Karpov is
threatening to jump to d6 with the night
after he for example plays rook to d1
and this was a perfect opportunity for
Karpov to actually play rook to d1 going
for the d7 pawn also threatening some
ideas like Knight to d6 practically
forcing a move like Bishop to c6 this
wood block Tony's control of the C file
and the game goes on it's a pretty cool
position you know perfectly playable but
after this rook a to c8 move
Karpov for some reason as Myles explains
it played Queen to b3 immediately and it
seems like a powerful idea there should
be one Queen d3 eyeing that h7 square
Knight to f6 could be coming Knight to
g5 could be coming so you know seems
like a lot of serious serious threats
here but this was actually a pretty
serious blunder by Karpov as Myles
immediately punishes this he plays rook
captures on c1 now we don't really have
any options of playing Knight somewhere
because rook captures and f1 is coming
with tempo so first Cup Karpov
recaptured route captures and c1 and now
we have Queen captures on b2 you know
very rude of Tony miles the grabbing
upon like that but it's not actually
just grabbing upon it's grabbing upon
with tempo on the rook still there are
no tactics available for Karpov because
Queen captures on c1 is a terrible
threat so rook to e1 and now again a
very nice move by Myles Queen captures
on e5 again now pressuring this night
with the bishop and the Queen and also
the knight is again unable to move
because the queen is now x-raying the
rook anyone
so here copper really doesn't have any
good options he played queen capture Sun
d7 now attacking the boat sorry both
Bishop on b7 and Bishop on e7 but here
miles simply plays Bishop to b4 getting
out of the attack and now attacking
carpals undefended broken
one here couple really doesn't have a
good option here probably capturing the
bishop with the Queen and given up the
exchange but that's just a slow death so
instead he decided to play rook to e3
hoping for some maybe rook lifts or
something but now you you see that even
the great world champion Anatoly Karpov
falls to some weak back rank ideas as a
Myles plays Queen to d5 and the White
Queen has nowhere to go only only we
square where she can go is Queen to c7
but then comes Queen to d1 and this
leads to checkmate as the king is a very
weak here so Karpov has to exchange
Queens here and he has to go in a very
unfavorable endgame for him being a pawn
down and with Myles having now a very
strong disrepair so Queen captures we
have Bishop captures and now I think any
one of you could play this position
against Karpov and you know you would
not lose a couple play Knight to c3 rook
the c8 now pinning the night as there
are again some weaknesses on the back
back rank so knife to e2 preventing the
rook from coming to see one now comes
g5h for bringing the King into the game
King to g 7h captures h captures Bishop
to d3 a5 now we have root 2 G 3 knocking
to f6 defending the g5 pawn rook to g4
now Bishop Theresa Bishop to d6 King to
f1 carpeau also tries to bring his King
into the game Bishop to e5 now and now
we see how dominant this position is
Myles his rook is controlling the the C
file these these bishops are amazing
here the dark square bishop is really
controlling all of the squares the
knight can jump two and the two the two
bishops are really creating a nice wall
here
it's it's like a it's like a completely
dominant position for black so king t1
by Karpov rook to h8 going for that h1
square F for now G characters on f4
Knight captures and Bishop to c6 not
allowing the bishop prepare to be to be
eliminated nice to eat tuna comes rotate
one trip
Kings to d2 and now rook to h2 check
going after the G to pawn there is no
way to defend the G do porn and since
Karpov is already down upon he really
can't afford to lose any other pawns
so g3 and now comes Bishop to f3 malice
is preparing roof to g2 attacking the G
to pawn and this Bishop to f3 comes with
the idea of removing the defender of the
g3 pawn so rough to g8 by Karpov now
simply rub the G to the knight can't
move it's pinned of course King to e2 e1
now comes Bishop captures I need to
removing the defender Bishop captures
and now rook captures and g3 now miles
is up two points and there is nothing
for Karpov to do here carful played rook
to e8 and I believe the game was
adjourned in this position and Tony
miles you know wrote down the move
Bishop to c7 and later when the game was
resumed he played Bishop to c7 and it
was in this position that world champion
Anatoly Karpov resigned at the game as
being two points down
he is completely defenseless here so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it
a nice a nice brilliant see if I do say
so myself by the English grand master
Tony miles and you know it's it's like
when he decided to play a six it's like
he completely threw carpeau off guard as
there were a lot of opportunities for
Karpov to grab some active play but
Karpov was really just just going for
worse moves even that Bishop to
sacrifice in h7 even if you play that
there's really it's really hard to
actually lose that with white I mean if
you don't want to go for when you're not
going to lose but you know that winter
d3 that point to degree was probably the
blunder that cost Karp of the game but
what's the moral of this story the moral
of the story is if you play against
someone in you play a weird move on move
one and someone tells you that that's
that's a terrible move that's not how
you play chess
you can always tell them that in 1980 in
the European Championship for Men
Anthony miles defeated Anatoly Karpov by
playing a six on the first move and you
immediately win that argument so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Mark Elkins for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot too really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here
I thank y'all for watching and I will
see you soon